all right all right we're live
or is it just
okay okay this is just me then
I'm turning off the air here it's very
loud
can you hear me okay
when you talk
I don't hear an echo at all
let me see one sec
oh
yeah
did that say something say something Joe
yes hello
oh that's it that was it that fixed it
yeah what was that
we have to look at uh you Joel the whole
time or how does that work
which which one
oh were you doing a joke
oh you you should be uh we're all next
to each other
how do I see that
on uh on YouTube are you in a different
screen
I'm on your street
uh
let me see
this is going great
this is a great start
I literally
that's exactly what I expected
I literally like I literally just got
here
oh you just got to Nashville
hello hello hello can y'all hear me
can y'all hear me you just got to
Nashville
yeah the cart thing is still in my room
oh wow like I literally just got here
and then I was like oh
so much stuff
I did
I'm all about convenience
but yeah I brought food I brought water
I brought my tech and I brought clothes
so yeah I had a few things going on here
smuggling I mean
I'll leave tomorrow night I'm doing
why is this still on can y'all
wait
how the hell do I turn that off
you still there
I'm here I can't see I had nothing but
my face I don't like that I mean I want
to see how I can't see you Yoshi at all
this area you gotta go you gotta you
gotta open a different window
into the YouTube and then uh mute that
line mute that version of it
ah
and then it's going to be a little bit
on a delay if you're trying to see all
the faces
oh my gosh we have okay we have people
watching oh my gosh
oh uh
okay cool okay yeah if you look on
YouTube we're all three here
yes
sorry everyone for the delay
I got my time change mixed up
oh thanks Yoshi was in the live chat
telling people that's terrible I know
but yeah I leave tomorrow yeah am I that
blurry to everyone else
are you what do you say
um
now am I that worried everyone else
uh
uh it looks like
why is that fan on
it's like can y'all hear that hum it's
like we can't hear it
but like I'm after I can't sleep in here
with that guys I'm
I can't be in hotel rooms where the AC
is
no that's not true
but yeah I'm just here for the for in
Nashville for the for tomorrow I'm doing
like a oh joke writing workshop for a
company
well I'm gonna teach these sales people
how to write a joke
and they're paying me money
awesome yeah I know right
it's so nice to get it's amazing when
that happens
[Laughter]
it truly is
yep you have a deal with this
with the streaming company
to use do you have a deal with them
yeah I have an affiliate link if anyone
would like to sign up
I just was gonna say stream yard teams
better
oh no no no no no definitely ecam can do
way more than stream yard for sure yeah
we've tried stream yard before yeah yeah
yeah
ecam is uh yeah it's way better but
stream yard is good for like basic like
you
don't have to watch the YouTube channel
to see all three faces but I don't
understand why that is because it's not
um
no no your whole setup remember Joel
your whole setup is different at the
house versus here
yeah yeah yeah
like Joe's got a separate screen you
know you've got like Graphics that come
into play or whatever like yeah we don't
have that on the laptop from the laptop
yeah I don't yeah I don't know why you
can't uh
does that do anything Joe
no no oh well
positions and my camera looks better
crappy I don't know I'm so sorry
no I don't care let's have fun all right
let's have fun everyone
now that we got now that we got all the
complaining out of the way
yeah hey I like the shirt Yoshi
what is he wearing
ooh World Series of Comedy
oh yeah
2020. I'm late baby yeah
hey well that's that's what we're here
that's what we're here to talk about my
friends
and we're uh we're doing a q a and we're
also here to talk about comedy festivals
so if we could uh Joe you've been on the
show before but could you introduce
yourself to the peeps watching live here
I am Joe lauers I'm the owner
and creator of the World Series of
Comedy
I think that's it I'm a cop I've been
doing comedy for 30 years uh
hey kids it's about brevity you know
what I mean like that's just
introduction brief
get to the point guys that's how you hit
it
I started the festival because I love
Comics I love comedy I love helping
comics and that's what it's about
I think
that's all there is
yeah I think that's what we we talked a
lot about yesterday
or last week and what inspired us to
bring you on is because we ended up
talking we talking about festivals and
then we kept talking about World Series
and just how much like networking is
done there and like the opportunities
that Yoshi and I have both gotten from
being a part of it so we're like we
might as well just bring the guy on
himself
yeah I love it I mean I love there's a
lot of con a lot of festivals out there
and a lot of them are really good and as
long as they are fair and honest and
keep doing a good job then I don't care
how many there are I you know just get
as many as they can and give as many
opportunities as possible
I'm super anal about the rules I want
everything to be fair and honest and fun
and I keep the roles pretty tight so I'm
able to become friends with a lot of
comics and uh it's it's a lot of fun
lots of networking uh everything Yoshi's
been to the main event you've come to a
couple satellites you did the main event
once too Joe you came out and did a
podcast seminar which was super cool
that's something that we do at the main
we have uh seminars two of them every
day for five days a week so Comics who
register even if they don't uh get
selected to be part of the top 101
it's just a ton of networking and
I I tell Congress all the time if you're
registering
to win this thing keep your money
because it's hard it's really hard you
got to beat out 500 and some Comics to
win this thing it's not easy it's it's a
tough road but if you want to rest your
because you want to see where you fall
in that scale of comics where if you can
get to perform in some clubs that you
have never performed in Yoshi came out
to California that was like a week and a
half ago or something like that I think
yeah she was out there got from two
different clubs no just one
yeah
yeah but it was cool it was great he did
great and it was fun seeing him perform
at a different location
yeah it was a good set I had a good set
I was very happy with it oh I was I
thought you were hey I'm just watching
you grow from last year when I saw you
at the punch line it was really fun to
see you uh get better
thanks man yeah no it was a good set I
was happy with it very happy with it
um and like uh Joe said like I think the
biggest thing about the festival is
really about that Network
and you know I think we talked about it
a lot Joel how a lot of the gigs that
you're going to get are going to come
from other comedians so if especially
when other comedians you know you go
through a certain city or you're
traveling and you hit up other
communities like hey is there a show
that I can get on I think that's truly
how you get better uh is by performing
outside of your main city as well
uh I think that's definitely like one of
those comedy nuggets that I've heard
over all the interviews that Joe's been
doing as well is like travel outside of
your city to see if your Comedy Works
outside of your own town
yeah I love it I mean
Yoshi you came in and you stayed at
Jim's house
yeah
so I mean now you know you can go to San
Diego California you got a place to hang
even if you want to go out
stay just for a little bit you know and
I and I think we should just give Jim's
address and phone number to every comic
whether they know him or not
it is a nice house so I just don't think
he wants strangers in there he's he's he
doesn't like people very much it's a
very small amount of people that he
likes
yeah I happen to make the list
of the world I truly love it
love it I'm coming busting the balls of
another comic about something and I know
that they didn't know each other before
the World Series and they're just having
a good time you know being smart with
each other but I also know that they
become friends because of this and
that's that's really cool I mean it's
really fun to see
yeah
yeah and I we got a question
Sandy had asked uh yeah I mean I'm here
well if we're talking about our
experience in the World Series every
time I've gone I've booked work and I've
met new comedians that I still keep in
touch with that yeah I've met every
every time I've done a World Series
event I've done I've gotten more out of
it than I expected I think
after the World Series was actually the
first show I did
during the pandemic like I think during
the pandemic I did like one college and
then nothing else so I was one of the
judges at the punch line in Atlanta so
I'm judging comedians on how funny they
are and I haven't been on stage in
months
and then I'm going up doing like 15. I'm
up there's flop sweating like oh my gosh
but it was good yeah
I mean even if you
have money Jason
rvp's never performed comedy but he's
incredible at giving notes and and
knowing what clubs and stuff want to see
and that's really what we're working on
we're uh we want to we try we this
Festival is about trying to get Comics
work in comedy clubs so every time we
give any kind of advice anything we talk
to you about a lot of times it has
nothing to do with
necessarily what I think I mean I might
love it if you go up and swear and go
nuts on stage but I'm probably going to
tell you hey man you got to cut that
back a little bit if you want to get
worked in a club as a feature Act I love
that it might not be the right work for
that and that's what we try to always
help with what's Sandy's question who's
Sandy Sandy Bernstein up in the the
Baltimore area
um
she asked how can you engage an audience
without asking questions I know not to
put
that in the submission video but what
about in real life
in real life like off stage like just
walking around you just walk up to
people because that's weird she's like
how do you how do you start a
conversation what are some good
icebreakers
uh
I don't know is she talking off stage or
on stage
yeah on a stage yeah how do you engage
an audience without asking another way
to ask the question is how do you do
crowd work without asking questions
uh
there's two types of questions that do
crowd work I taught a crowd work seminar
uh last year at the main event I'm going
to do it again this year and crowd work
I would say the majority of comics don't
understand what crowd work is they think
just be you know hey they drive here or
anybody have a car or you know
how many married couples are out there
that's not crowd work that's just uh
asking questions for no reason
and that to me is like if we see that in
the video we're probably taking points
off for it uh I I it screams to me a new
comic or insecure about your material if
you're up there and you say hey did
anybody drive here that means you have a
joke about driving somewhere and you
just want the audience to say yeah we
drove so you feel comfortable we all
know you drove uh I asked in my show I
do a lot of improv I asked controlled
questions I know what the answers are
that I'm going to get back or I force
the audience to give me the answers I
want or close to it I've been doing this
long enough that I play off of their
answers
if it works so I mean there's that's the
difference the questions I'm asking are
I don't know how to I'm trying to
describe like they're in my joke they're
uh
I I I I
talk I ask people what they do for a
living a lot in my show which that's a
normal question to ask but a lot of
comics don't go any farther with it I
play off what they said I had so many
people tell me what they do that I have
kind of jokes in my head if they say
this if they say that I do that several
times until they have uh until I feel
like I've pushed it far enough with the
audience and then I say the reason I ask
is because the other day I was doing the
show and I asked a woman what she did
for a living and she said she was an
x-ray technician and I of course asked
her the first question came in my mind
what's the weirdest thing you've ever
found of someone's ass
and then solid I asked the audience I go
what was it what do you think it was
people that that causes people to yell
out I know they're going to yell out and
I play off of everything that they yell
out if it's something I never heard then
I'll put on a spot to come up with what
you know what about it uh somebody
yelled out toothbrush the other night
and nobody's ever yelled toothbrush and
I kind of made some jokes about that
somebody yelled out a baby doll head
and then she said it was actually five
big comments and I made up a whole bunch
of stuff about that and then I went into
what it was
and and I go from there so
I know where they're gonna go with each
question I ask I know which route I'm
gonna take with it uh
I did a whole I don't know what what do
you call them like a diagram I guess
where it starts here and if it goes this
way it's one thing it goes this way it's
another because this and it all just
leads down to where I want them to be
and I'm controlling the audience the
entire time I'm talking to them where
other Comics aren't controlling it if
you ask a question hey anybody drive
here
and they all know
you're still going to tell the joke
[Laughter]
but he married anybody have any
any you know I've seen it where people
yell out no there's no pet owners and
then I've seen Thomas go well
then this next joke's gonna suck
somebody in the audience has a pet
you're just afraid to talk about it if
you wanna if you want to engage them
about a pet
say you know pick a person say you look
like a dog or owner sir do you own a dog
and if they say no say oh man you look
like you should have a dog and this is
the reasons I think you should have a
dog and
pick that one person out if they say yes
say what kind of dog is it and get the
and then just be like oh man I really
had you down for a pit bull and whatever
it might be and just go from there and
push
don't just be General like any dog
owners that's not proper that's just
nothing about your work what I love is
Sandy's question was how to engage an
audience without asking questions and
Joe just listed a bunch of questions to
ask the audience to get into material
to crowd work you do
you do need to ask questions I mean only
thing I could think of would how to
engage an audience without asking
questions is like give give yourselves a
round of applause for being here like
I don't I don't know
what's up in the middle of the show as a
feature should do give yourself a round
of applause if you send a new video for
the world series of comedy and it has
give yourself up give your up for this
or a lot of thoughts for that every just
know every time you say that you're
probably losing a point from one of us
judges there's the host has already done
that job I guess to answer Sandy's
question if you want to engage an
audience uh keep going on stage every
chance you possibly can and keep
building your confidence through it's
through the roof and when soon as you if
you look at a comic who's confident that
walks on the stage uh
Yoshi uh last year he did great this
year but last year when he walked on
stage in Atlanta and that's his home
Club
the confidence was so he was cocky
it was beautiful he didn't say
his delivery was cocky the way he
dressed was cocky not in a bad way he
just was screaming I'm very confident
and I don't give a [__] if you like me
or not now he's down the side he doesn't
like him we all want that but he showed
I'm fine with where I'm at and that's
that's a great way to engage once you
let the audience know I'm comfortable up
here and they're like okay and now
you're engaging them they want you think
about anywhere you're at if somebody's a
good talker or somebody says things or
looks confident no matter where you're
at
you want to hear them that's why car
salesmen are car softly they're they're
good at that I mean they may be annoying
sitting around a table but they're good
at telling you about cars
um speaking of that as you talked a
little bit about some of the stuff that
you've seen on videos uh another
question came through can you talk a
little bit more about maybe like three
to four things that you'd recommend
from a submission video that people
should do like some tips
it's funny I
we watch every single video but it's in
and we all are looking for you know
stage presence originality and overall
that's what we're looking for but we all
have some different things
that we look at and then we sometimes go
over the like Jason and I both hate if a
Comics is like guys you know what I mean
guys okay guys guy I mean there's times
we start a case counter and how many
times they you know watch your how you
tell your jokes and if you maybe that's
how you talk off stage but sometimes you
gotta change that or be aware of that uh
I'm a big stickler on
the mic and the mic stand and not
messing if I see a comic leaning on the
mic stand uh you're not good enough to
lean on the mic stand uh
[Laughter]
if the club owner has to go to Guitar
Center on Monday
you're not coming back so don't break if
you're looking on a mic stand and you
break it those things are I mean how
many times have you done a show where
the mic stands [__] it's not screwed in
tight it's falling down it's broken
that's because other Comics have [__]
it up yeah
[Laughter]
so I've been doing comedy for 30 years
if somebody hands me a mic when I'm
walking on stage I'm like I don't want
to touch it I I want it in a stand so if
you're opening up for me and you break
the mic stand guess who's not opening up
for me the next time
I I don't care how funny you are I need
that mic stand I want that mic stand so
it's may sound trivial there's there's
so many little things that Comics don't
think of they're like well I'm funny
that's why I should get hired
yeah but if you're funny and you break
the equipment
there's other funny guys that don't
break the equipment if you're funny and
you don't have
English where you're pushing them just
saying things over you know like like I
mean a lot of comics that you're like
you know what I mean like like this like
that like it's like oh it's [__] just
take walk out of it I don't know if I'm
supposed to be swearing on here or not I
should ask that person you're good
should people swear in their submissions
is that is that a is like dirty
we tell Comics you're submitting for uh
future work
so yeah you can swear if you can work
when I'm watching a video if you're
swearing for no reason
that could cost you points but if
there's a reason for it I swear a lot in
my show but I do it I guess I do it in
such a way that I'm pretty likable and
people don't sometimes don't realize
that I've had old ladies smoke we go you
were great you hardly sworn I'm like
holy [__]
but I mean if
so yeah I mean if the joke's good but I
mean being clean
or cleaner as a comic is going to take
you farther as a new comic you're gonna
every Booker looks at every video and
every comic as where can I put that
how will they work in my club so
if you are a clean cleaner comic now I
can and you know you get a hold of me
and you're like Hey man can I come this
in this weekend and I have a super dirty
headliner like oh that'd be perfect this
clean guy if I have a really dirty
headliner or super clean headliner and
you're dirty
you you might not maybe the dirty
headliner says I don't want somebody
dirty in front of me I want somebody to
clean
or the clean guy definitely doesn't want
somebody dirty in front of them so now
you've just limited this 52 weeks a year
and this that means that's so that's
some the number of weeks that you can
work as a comic if you limit those that
number by being too dirty you just cut
your work time down
so less I mean less than that I mean for
some of the clubs yeah maybe you can get
your 50 weeks full and some one-nighters
and stuff like that I my show when I
started I was pretty dirty and I cleaned
it up
did everything to clean up my show which
most Comics who know me go there's no
way yeah that's how I cleaned myself
I clean my show up so I could get work
so I could become a headliner to do
whatever the [__] I want
and if you're opening up for me if
you're really dirty that's fine but if
you're extremely dirty that means I have
to be dirtier so I'm gonna be like uh
should you not be so dirty because I'm
and they'll be like you're dirty and I'm
like yeah but I have to push it farther
[Music]
working clean is green
you said working clean is green
yep
Dennis told you know so you had to Club
it I mean I figured stuff out but I mean
yeah he knows he does the uh
economy stuff I mean it's great it's
smart it's and it sucks because I mean I
mean it doesn't suck if that's the way
you want to be but I mean if you want to
be a dirty comic sometimes you're like
oh well I want to do what I want to do
well that's great do what you want to do
uh just don't [__] when somebody's
getting work at a club and you're not
know why I don't think it's you know oh
they don't like me or they don't want me
they they may love you I've had hookers
at the comedy of the World Series of
Comedy judging Comics going oh my God I
love this comic I don't think I can work
them in my club
so because their Club doesn't hire that
30 of a comic or something but they like
the show they just
it's it's about getting work that's what
this is all about and if you want to get
work sometimes you've gotta I went to uh
art school that's what I did before I
was doing comedy and I used to have uh
other Arts students that I was going to
school with they'd be like I I hate this
being told what I have to draw and I go
well then quit this school and go to a
final and you can draw whatever the [__]
you want but if you're an advertising
School you get a job at an advertising
department and you do what you're told
and then on the weekends you do fine art
you build something stupid out of nuts
and bolts
but I mean and that's comedy when you
start out you've got to do
become a good host if you become a good
host you're invaluable
yeah like I when I started uh once I
realized that most of the shows I was
going to be working on were two-man
shows
and that I was going to be the opening
one I started working on trying to be
better at hosting
because then I was valuable to the
two-man show because and my show was
better and I had more fun because I'd
walk out and kind of do a little bit of
Hosting thing that I'd go into my show
and and then the headliners are like oh
this guy really got the audience going
and stuff so then they would want to
bring me more
until I learned that I was having
sometimes I'd have a good show and
sometimes it'd be shitty because I was
like I'm the middle act I'm coming out
it's like well there's really no
other apps so there's really not a
middle act it's just a two-man show
so when you become a good host you're
going to step above every other comic
too
yeah what are uh keto Carol asked some
tips for being a great host
I taught seminar on uh hosting two at
the main event one year and we we almost
always have the seminar going on for
that my
thing is and I tell this to any comic
who wants to know about hosting is when
you walk into a room as a comic and you
see an audience sitting there
they're not an audience they're just a
group of individuals sitting at a table
different tables they're not an audience
until the host makes them an audience
there and the host's job is you have to
make them work together at least three
times uh years ago when my wife and I
went out to Las Vegas we went to see uh
search show uh oh this is before we
moved to
to Vegas and there was probably about 2
000 people in the room and as an
Entertainer I was listened to all these
people talking and I was like oh man how
are they going to get them all to shut
up for the show
because they were just mumbling and all
you could hear is talking from table to
table table
and all of a sudden two guys came out
with a big inner tube and they wheeled
it across the stage they were mice but
you could hardly hear them and they're
fighting
and by the time they got that tune from
one side of the states to the other you
could hear a pin drop in that room
everyone was listening and I remember
sitting there and I don't know if
anybody else had the same feeling
because they maybe they were a stand-up
comedy or whatever but I remember going
holy [__] they just made the audience a
group we were all doing one thing
together and I went to the blue band
group and once again large audience
we're all talking I'm talking with the
people that I'm with these people are
talking with the people they're with all
of a sudden I hear Happy Birthday Joel
and I'm like looking around I realize
there's like a little ticker tape thing
across the stage and it's just saying
hey everybody on the count of three wish
Joel a happy birthday
and then it would count down
and then it people yeah and then sooner
by the third one hey everybody wish so
and so happy anniversary
by the third one everybody in the
audience was going
reading that and yelling and then the
curtain went up and the show started
all we have is give it up for so I hate
if you send a video out to get work
as a feature act with the cheerleading
[__] but as a host you should really
have that you should walk out
and be like you know give it up for your
headliner who's in the back that's not
so the headliner can hear it who gives a
[__] a few years people thought you know
he's here he came all the way in from
Las Vegas give it up for Joe hours make
him feel welcome give it up for him hey
that's one Applause give it up for your
future act Yoshi he's here from Atlanta
he's gonna kill it for you you know it's
going to be great let him hear it that's
two Applause hey man I'm your host I'm
gonna be up here all night you might as
well just applaud for me give it up for
that
that's three
at that point you can maybe I always
look at somebody and be like and give it
up for this guy's shirt
uh you know and if it's something what
will happen there is if they laugh that
lets you know as a comic they're
probably ready to hear your first joke
as a Comics want to just do their
material they don't want to host there's
very few Comics that you come across
going oh I love hosting I want a host so
they go up they make the announcements
they fly through the [__] as quick as
possible just so they can get the
material they tell their first joke and
it goes to [__] then the whole they
start to panic show goes downhill and
they're and they walk off feeling like
crap and they're like what happened what
what happened well the audience wasn't
ready
they weren't ready to laugh yet they
didn't know
that they were supposed to start
laughing together so you throw out a
little tester joke maybe you throw out
some other little joke that's that you
don't care if they laugh at if they
laugh at it then you go all right now
they're ready and then you can kind of
get into it if they're not make them
applaud for something else give it up
for the restaurant uh give it up for the
food give it up for the sign on the wall
you know find something that they're
probably gonna lie that's stupid like
percent of the wall and if they laugh at
that dumb thing like you said they're
probably ready so now they're an
audience now they're ready to work
together and now you have fun the best
hosting is when you walk off and
everybody walks by you at the end of the
show and tell us the other Comics how
good they did if that happens you did
your job
it's a shitty job it sucks and sometimes
you don't get the credit but if you do a
really good job I've had a hosts come up
to me and going oh that was terrible I
did so bad and I'm like look what's
happening right now this comic is
killing it
so I know it sucks but you did your job
there the audience was ready for that
yeah your job is basically to just
transform them from a a
what'd you say an audience to a group
or from a bunch of individuals
individuals into it yeah
they can just walk up and they just jump
right into material like that's it like
they just start their material at the
beginning of this entire show you got to
kind of ease you know gotta lube it up
yeah
loose lips that's what happens when you
get around go Joe's like he was rubbing
off on me over here yeah
she was like yeah I really think you
should do clean but you know [__] that
[__] yeah
that's right though
whoa can we copy that you say I was
right Joe's right
it's a ringtone
of just that like
you can do dirty as long as you're not
doing dirty for the sake of doing dirty
like I think you bring up a good point
about just if you go too dirty you have
to like someone else has to kind of go
dirtier after you and if you're
featuring
um I know I featured for someone who
does Super dirty and they were
um they were like oh I want clean
material that way I have room to be
dirty but the audience appreciates the
clean material because the audience
wasn't necessarily there for you they're
there for the headliner and so I just
think comedy clubs think about that when
they're putting up their lineup together
and sometimes it'll be a headliner that
wants that but sometimes it's the club
that has that requirement and the clubs
and they know what kind of makes Their
audience tick as well
um yeah
yeah
the future they don't want a headache
they don't want somebody coming up to
them and saying yeah that middle guy was
yeah they don't want comedy guards
yeah
yeah they don't want bad Yelp reviews
nature at the club oh my God maybe that
maybe the headline they didn't request
it but I mean I also I was on the road
for a lot of years and there were so
many times where I showed up and it's
funny I would call my wife the next day
and I'd be talking her head off and
she'd be like oh you don't like the ACT
you're working with and I'm like
how do you know and she goes because you
didn't must not have talked to them that
much
talking to me too much
yeah and yeah so I mean I I loved it
when I as soon as I got to that's the
other thing too is if you are a really
good strong teacher and Headliners start
to like you as soon as I was to the
point where I could tell the club hey
I'd like to bring my opener
I did that and I always brought one of
my friends somebody who I had two or
three guys in Pittsburgh that I always
try to take with me because I knew I was
going to have a fun week I knew they
were going to do a great job in front of
me but it was not going to be annoying
drive me crazy or anything like that
yeah one week it would be a good show
and so that's another reason you might
want to do it because you you should you
should always try to find
a headliner in your hometown and ask
them how you can help them
can I drive you to a gig can I film you
whatever you might I had two brand new
cars when I started darn comedy I went
up to every headliner in the city of
Pittsburgh and said I'll drive you to
any gig you can choose which car you
want if you want to pay me
for the gas you can if not I'll eat it
they all did they all pitched in and I
was featuring on the road in six months
should I have been no
um
yeah and I got better and I had some
shows where like the next time that
headliner was going back to the club and
I'd be like hey can I come in there like
no they don't want you
but I I grew fast I learned I learned
fast about the business I underst I took
right from the very start I took comedy
as a business not as
uh my job getting on stage not
performing performance to pay off
many many times every single one of us
as Comics has done our shows for
hundreds or thousands of dollars and
also done that exact same show for free
and there's not too many people
yeah but so that's how dumb we are as
Comics but I mean it's also shows how
much we love what we do but if you look
at it as business and say what can I get
out of that pre-show what can I use it
for uh
how can I grow
the job comics and not enough Comics
take
the business side of it the way they
should
you should be hustling working hard not
overbearing not being annoying but you
should be on top of things
and if somebody tells you to email you
on a Tuesday don't email them on
Wednesday and then be like oh they
didn't hire me
I think you said that in like a previous
podcast we did about like just being
professional
like on stage is just a very small part
of the job it's like yeah being easy to
work with being on time like all these
little things I think a lot of comics
Overlook that can actually be the
difference between you getting booked
more or not
yeah I can see it at the main event
there's some Comics that I go
this guy's gonna end up getting work and
this one's not going to work and they're
equally fine
it's just one is running around with a a
notebook and a book jumping onto pokers
when they walk into a room and the other
one's just hanging out and
shooting the [__] with them
these club Owners and these Bookers are
people and they don't want to be
attacked
you know and
don't take things personal
so many Comics get taken everything
personal they're just like oh he didn't
respond to my email they must hate me
they probably don't even know who you
are yeah thank you
so many comments
if I respond up just uh pretty much
every email I get that's but it's my job
to do that you pay the comics who paid
for the festival I feel like I'm
somewhat working for them they're not
working for me I work for them they've
they did my Festival so I try to respond
to every email and try to help everybody
I can in any way I can and it takes a
ton of my time sometimes things get
neglected other work that I have to do
because I have to go through 50 emails
in a day uh but Bookers don't have to do
that
and if they responded to every email
that they get from Comics then there'll
be no club for you to go work at hmm
they're the other stuff they have to pay
the bills they have to make sure the
staff is going to be there for that week
they have to book for future weeks they
have to make sure the Electric's going
to stay on so you have a microphone to
talk into they have to go back to the
Guitar Center and buy a new mic stand
because the idiot last week broke their
[__] mic stand
it's all about that
they're like oh he didn't respond they
don't want me
they didn't respond because they don't
need you right now
um
[Music]
big facts uh another question here from
uh Jessica
rabid
do you have any tips not Jessica Rabbit
do you know her
rabbit
[Laughter]
r-a-b-i-d
Joel Joel okay pause
do you know who Jessica Rabbit is
Jessica Rabbit like rabbit like rabbit
like the the animal yeah
yeah
Jessica Rabbit I don't know Jessica
Rabbit am I supposed to know her
am I better get canceled is this a setup
what's happening
no it's not a setup but he made a joke
about the name and I I saw it in your
face and in your age you were like oh I
don't know what the hell this is
oh that's a rabbit
shelf look it up under you know oh Who
Framed Roger Rabbit
yes there we go
what is that is that a movie or
something
[Laughter]
Who Framed Roger Rabbit gotcha that's a
deep cut yay yeah throw a light bulb all
over your house
be great if we have some cartoon
that was a good question actually have
you heard of me so we got we got to the
bottom of that
that was not a question
yeah hers was about uh do you have any
tips for stage presence slash joke
delivery
stage precious I think stage presence is
uh
just gonna come
and I guess joke delivery that's all
going to come with time uh State just
getting paid as much as you can uh I
remember when I started there was a
comic in Pittsburgh who
and just before I understood joke
writing and different things but I
remember watching him and thinking well
these jokes seem like they should be
getting a lot but they're not and I
didn't know why I didn't understand even
how to help him but then I remember like
but he'd go up every week and do the
same thing and then all of a sudden like
one week he went up and it
slaughtered and I was like holy [__] and
and then he started going good and it
was kind of like
it was just from him doing it and he
finally figured out how to be himself on
stage and stuff and I think that's where
stage presence comes just being on stage
more and more the more you're up there
the more you'll get comfortable and feel
comfortable with the microphone
uh
I asked Comics all the time if they own
a mic and a mic stand and I say do you
know any guitarist in a band that don't
that doesn't own a guitar
right
the mic and the mic stand is our toll
and if you I watch comic shows fall
apart because the cord was wrapped
around the mic stand or because they
couldn't figure out how to take the mic
out of the mic stand comfortably even if
it messes up if you've done it a million
times I have Comics there was a comic in
Colorado one year where he went to take
the mic out of the mic stand and the
whole clip came off and you the audience
may not have even known that happen
he was so calm and cool about it he went
on with his show and after the show I
was like that was beautiful he's like
what and I go the fact that you did your
show and it didn't affect you that the
mic stand had messed up
he he didn't let and then I've watched
other people where they were just trying
to get it out and then they're fumbling
and
and it messes the whole show I've had
I've seen Comics slip out on a host
because they said their name wrong and
that's why their show went to [__]
really uh
I mean learn to deal with that quite
often who gives a crap
how they say your name I mean it's
script names all the time when I'm on
state bringing up the winners and Yoshi
can you know he's heard me probably do
it a million times but
he does it's regular
yeah but I mean uh they the comics are
they're excited they're coming up
because they won but I mean so stage
presence and deliver your jokes I think
that's just the time thing do it as much
as you can on stage and you'll get
better you'll start to feel comfortable
and all that'll start to
happen naturally I mean that's one of
the things I love about the World Series
watching Comics register sometimes they
don't the first year they register they
don't get selected but they come to the
main event they see the networking they
do all that the next year they register
maybe they don't make it to the main
event and they come to a couple
satellites that get involved in some
satellites and we get to work with them
and try to help with their jokes and
how they're going on stage and stuff
like that and we watch them grow and get
better and then all of a sudden the next
year they're in the main event and
they're
doing really well and it's fun to watch
Comics grow that way
someone told me when I started it takes
five years before you get comfortable on
stage I was like oh that's [__] it
won't take that long I was young I was
cocky I think that person was wrong
I think it takes 10 years
so many Comics the hearts just dropped
I've been doing it 10 months
I think it now takes I personally
honestly think before you truly start to
click all the time it takes 15 maybe
more
before because at five six years in
you're gonna have shows where
everything's perfect and you're gonna be
like that's it I know what I'm doing I
got it and then the next night you're
gonna go up and eat a bag of dicks and
you'll be like what the [__] just
happened it did everything exactly the
same
presence
bring the jokes yeah
yeah and you'll become a better joke
writer too like anybody who's on this
podcast watching right now they're
watching because of because of you guys
every week going over this stuff and
Joel you have that the joke the word of
the date what is it what do you call
that I love it
and so I read them all the time when I
see them and sometimes I'm like oh
that's a good one and sometimes I'm like
that's okay but I sit here
time if they put they put some work into
it and
the fact that they're working on it is
you're just going to make their jokes
stronger later on they're just going to
be stronger at writing a joke and then
the more stage presence you you're gonna
and there's going to be natural
performers
and natural right better writers I'm a
better performer on stage than I am a
writer
and writers once writers catch up with
the performers they're probably usually
always going to blow us away
like I had to learn to write better
because I was getting work early on
because I was high energy and jumping
around and acting stupid and making
faces and that worked fine for a little
bit and then all of a sudden people were
like that's not enough you have anything
really funny to say and I was like oh
[__] I better figure out how to say
something
[Laughter]
[Music]
where good writers are writing to tell
good jokes right away
but sometimes they're not performing
those jokes they're just telling them
so
yeah and when you rehearse yeah zainova
asked when like you're rehearsing do you
do it in front of a mirror
foreign
that's why I think you should have a mic
and a mic stand so you could rehearse at
home and you could take the mic out of
the mic stand and feel comfortable with
it and put the mic behind you if you're
not going to use if you don't use the
microwave put it behind you yeah
rehearsal in front of a mirror and if
you have 20 minutes at home you have
about six minutes on stage
so any comic it's like I got 20 minutes
and sat in front of an audience or is
that in front of a mirror because you
are gonna
appreciate the state you're going to
start talking faster you're going to
forget how
to video stuff if you want to get picked
for the World Series and probably most
festivals and work make sure your video
does not have notes in it don't take
notes on stage boom walk up on stage
with notes and set it down on a thing
you're pretty much done boom
I agree yeah I'm annoyed with these kids
bringing notes up like well what do you
want to talk about next do you have five
minutes at an open mic and they're like
oh what else is there
and a lot of comics are doing this too
they take their phone off and they set
their they're like oh I had my uh
stopwatch on it well we don't know that
when you're watching a video
so to me it looks like you're looking at
notes and if that's what it looks like
to me that's what it looks like to a
Booker
and the book is like I'm not hiring some
amateur who doesn't know his stuff now I
mean if you're going up to work stuff
out at an open mic yeah take your piece
of paper out you know or your phone and
look at your stuff even at an open mic
if you need to work it out at an open
mic but if you're sending a video out to
try to get work so you don't think they
should take it up on an open mic either
Joel I I think it's all annoying I don't
I think they need to learn how to sit in
that discomfort of forgetting something
and understand how to power through
those moments instead of well let me go
to this paper
they should work on crazy with the
audience
I agree with that but what if it's like
a brand new joke that you just want to
remember like it's not part of your set
you just like to me like
uh yeah okay that's cool I love it yeah
I mean I love your I love the attitude I
like being forced I think that's great I
take it I take a clipboard
Joe's unforgiving on notes he's like new
joke it better be uh remember to the
Finish Line before you try it yeah
it will definitely differ me and Joe
definitely differ on the notes because
I'm like at an open mic that I'm first
of all I'm not recording an open mic I
think I've said this you can back me up
uh Joe if you think this is true you
should not submit an open mic set for
the World Series or for a Comedy
Festival you should submit a showcase
set yay or nay correct
okay you should never
or nay nay that would be Nathan right
yes yes
you should not submit an open mic set
don't don't send that in
if you're a newer comic who wants to
register for the festival for because
you want to get feedback on your video
and you want to learn about your jokes
and know what the world series of Comedy
thinks
then yeah go ahead and do it and submit
it but only do that if you're planning
on coming to the main event and being
around the seminars but no that you're
probably not going to get selected
because of that
but if you are really wanting to get
selected for one of these things
do what Yoshi said and get yourself
booked at a showcase somewhere
or try to at least and
do a nice showcase set without notes and
without you know saying what's what are
we doing next or anything like that and
hit us with a show
a polished the best polish five minutes
you possibly can and give it to us if
you happen to be at the road featuring
pick to me and you know you want to use
that video to send out do the best five
you can up front so we don't have to
edit it
um editing videos or I I don't care some
people care if you have it and stuff
like that I don't if you cut give us the
whole joke we've had people send us like
a commercial like they're just
highlights of the joke and I'm like well
I don't know if that's funny I mean you
told the setup great but I don't know
what to put like then you cut to the
next thing and it's like and their names
shooting across and also when you send a
video out
[Laughter]
I know
there's probably a hundred times when I
make a note uh it took you 15 seconds
before you started to talk it took 10
seconds before you started to talk and
that to me is annoying that's enough for
a club owner to turn the video off and
not hire you so then when you're going
man why would they didn't even watch my
video Yeah well
just cut your name
across the screen if you can do Graphics
or if the host or somebody that's
bringing you up said your name leave
that part and then but if you have a 25
minute uh stroll onto the stage before
you talk cut that [__] out because we're
watching five minutes we we got a video
one time
and it starts off
in the comic on stage is like [__] you
and just screaming way worse than I ever
said stuff to a woman in the audience
and I'm like holy [__] and then he goes
all right let me bring up your first
comic
wasn't the comic we were supposed to
watch
but everyone he sent that video to shut
it off
every Booker every Pub owner every
manager shut that video off
[Laughter]
because that dude couldn't find a 12
year old to do some editing for him oh
that's hilarious
I'm like this isn't even the person that
we're supposed to be watching
that'd be like having Kanye be your
opener that's incredible dude
don't send us a video from the show
from the shower
correct
you got that before
oh yeah curtain opens up
there
somebody sent me a video Once on their
pictures
thank you
and then they sent me an email going hey
how come I didn't get selected
and I said well
your kitchen
so we couldn't really get good points on
stage presence
and it was hard you know we really need
to see you on some sort of stage we're
for the festival we don't care if it's
an open Bike World we're never going to
judge anybody we never look at the
background and go oh they're in a club
so it's got to be better than the guy in
the at the open mic I don't give a [__]
where it's at as long as it's in front
of an audience of some sort that you're
standing on a stage uh
so the guy says to me he goes can I send
you one from my living room
would that be better and I'm like no I
don't think so
he did he did send one for me
[Music]
it was better no it wasn't better yeah
[Laughter]
you say it's okay to submit from an open
mic if it's like an open mic with like
an actual audience and not like all
comedians like you're fine with that
it's all comedian trip to Comic does it
right videos
we're saying no don't do Open Mic videos
if you're working out new material and
taking up notes but if you go to an open
mic if an open mic is the only place you
have and you go up to the uh thing
here's here's the other thing Comics do
is they'll show up at an open mic or
they'll show up somewhere and the club
will be like or that person will be like
hey can you do 10 and they'll be like
yeah I'll do 10. but they really only
need five for this video
so you should be showing up at every
Open Mic you can as soon as you decide
to register for any Festival not just
ours find out how long the video should
be
then go to Every Open Mic every club
that you can get a guest spot on and if
they offer you more time say you know
what I really just want the five can I
just do the five and go up and do the
type five don't try to get the best ten
five out of that 10 Because You're Gonna
Save something or something's gonna
happen at minute seven or eight that you
would have rather had in that five so
just do five get a solid five actually
work on the five minutes you're supposed
to send in
there's so many Comics that don't get in
and then they go oh I didn't really
think the video made had that big of a
deal it's like how you think we're just
randomly picking names out of a hat I
don't know who you are we watch the
videos we pick from the video that's all
we have to go on
work on your video work on your five
minute set like
it'll just make you better for
everything that way if you get the
opportunity and you're driving to a town
and you stop at this a room Club you'd
like to work in and they go and 90 of
the time they're gonna be like uh all
right you could have five minutes well
if you haven't worked on your five and
you don't have a strong you might have a
strong five but it's mixed in with 15
other things
then you're fumbling around in the back
of the room trying to write down how can
I what could I do here to make this work
and you go up and you maybe you kill it
or maybe you [__] the bed and you don't
get to work at that club ever again
if you have that strong five that you've
worked on and you show up at a club
anywhere you walk up and kill it they're
gonna be like well [__] if they can do
this at five what are they gonna do at
25. yeah I'll hurry
[Music]
um
practice Yeah
practice says set
yeah John John Lewis said
uh wanted to chime in I submitted to the
World Series of Comedy wanted to thank
Joe and his team for the work they put
in getting excellent notes back to us
the feedback is indeed amazing
it's amazing
um
what are the three things you uh review
a set on what are the three criteria
stage presence originality and overall
overall it's like what the judge
did I like it wasn't good
thing stage presence is what it is and
originality is like it you know
one year every comic that was submitting
not every but like every other one had a
dollar store joke as soon as it started
we were all uh and in my mind I'm always
like when that starts I'm like it better
be the best [__] Dollar Store joke
I've ever heard
there's different subjects it seems like
every year that somebody they get on and
and uh
just yeah so I mean we really work hard
with the notes and and sometimes Comics
get mad they're like I need my notes
it's like you're not the only one asking
for them or you know I have one guy uh
Dan fritchie who used to be one of my
hosts but his sole job for the festival
is to manage videos when they come in uh
when it's new videos changes to uh he
has to contact all the people for notes
he's bugging all the my video viewers
for notes constantly saying this I need
them all done with this date that's his
job he does it every day he works on it
every day just taking care of
the video submissions and stuff like
that for Commerce
so we try hard
I always feel like if you're gonna if
I'm gonna ask you to pay for this
Festival
and I know the majority of the comics
who are paying for this Festival
I don't know if it's a majority I guess
it would be are not going to get
selected for the satellites it's hard
it's hard to get selected for all of
them uh I want them to get something out
of it I want them to grow I don't want
to just take I had a comic one year who
this is early early on he registered uh
paid the money
didn't ask for notes never change this
video never did anything
he was the last Comic the very bot you
know on the list but he never never came
to the main event the next year
registered submitted the same video
never did anything never I told my wife
I go on the third year I said if he
registers again I'm sending him back his
money hmm she's like what I don't want I
go I don't want him just to register for
this festival and then not get anything
out of it that's stupid
I mean maybe he has enough money to do
that but
that's not what I see this stuff before
if you pay the money to register I want
you to get something out of it so the
notes
which we've had a lot of comics tell us
a notes alone are worth it
yeah that's yeah that's what uh John
said yeah the notes are worth it
uh what if what if they only have a
three minute set Oz was asking if the
open mic only allows three minutes do
you accept those
uh
my advice would be go to that open mic
twice
and do three different minutes
put it together send us the edited
version there you go one way you can do
three go the next uh if you have to
submit one of the first thing one of my
other big notes is
you only submitted a two minute video
you only submitted a three minute video
You're you've hurt your chances of
getting selected
know that we're watching the five
minutes so if you submit a three there's
one comic one year we've submitted a
three minute video who won this Festival
and uh there's Ty Rivera and he killed
it his three minutes was so incredible
that he didn't need any more most Comics
aren't going to have that
they're gonna you know they're gonna the
five is really nice so you're being
judged just know you're being judged
against other you can submit a three
minute I guess the simple answer is yeah
you can submit it just know that you're
lose you're being judged against every
other comic who submitted five so would
you we're seeing two more minutes of
someone else and that could cause that
other person to get one point more than
you which means could mean the
difference of you getting in or not
getting it
so nice well uh we've been going about
an hour here I think this could be a
good question to start Landing the plane
on of this is from six light dash of
what is the best comedy advice you've
received
uh
wow that's a hard one I don't know I uh
I remember uh years ago I there's a
couple comments but there I I went out
as a future Act and I
was doing my show and uh
my jokes weren't working that well and I
started ripping on the the jokes and
getting laughs so I started doing that
more it was just like I didn't care I
just wanted laughs and when I came off
the headliner said to me it's like uh
you have some really funny stuff stop
giving up on it so fast
and deliver with confidence like stand
there for a second and let them realize
the joke's over and stuff and that that
really helped me because I uh
I
realized
now I still have some jokes if it
doesn't work or I purposely write it so
I can go off on a tangent about
something messing up or rip on somebody
about it but it that really opened my
eyes to
just letting the audience know the
joke's over and standing there with
confidence saying I know it's funny you
should be laughing there and sometimes
that causes them to to start laughing
also one other time I went up on stage
and uh somebody heckled me this is very
early on in my career and I used to wear
a bowling shirt I still do when I go on
stage when I head down I wear a bowling
shirt bowling shoes and I look silly I
purposely want to look Goofy and chilly
on stage somebody heckled me and I tore
that person apart like just crushed him
I was so proud of what I had done like
this person had nothing left and I
walked off stage in a headliner said to
me goes what the [__] was that
and I go well he that's something so I
had to shut him up and he goes look at
you he goes you look like a silly fool
you can't see that
and I was like oh I never even thought
about how I look and how I
praying myself so from that point on
even to this day when before I go up to
headline I A lot of times in backstage
I'm like silly silly silly silly
reminding myself of how I look and I'm
probably meaner and more brutal now but
I do it in such a fun silly way that
people have come up to me off their
shoulder like obviously [__] the
whole show thanks man can I come back
and uh bring my cousin and let him be
the [__] like I call people names I
say but I do it in a fun way now so know
what you look like on stage and really
and know how you come across and if you
don't know ask other people ask friends
what do you what do I look like
do I look mean do I look happy
I do it all time with the World Series I
I almost come off and I go hey man you
need to look at that joke to me
I think I talked to you actually about
that once right
yeah yeah I was just gonna say uh one of
the things one of the notes from a
couple years ago when I before I did the
World Series or after the first year is
I did like ask for notes on sort of how
I come off on stage and I think it was
important for me to understand how I
came off on stage because I haven't
heard it from so many different types of
Bookers right and so I was very aware of
it and to recognize and address it
immediately so when you know when Joe
talks about like the way I came out like
in Atlanta and sort of you know yeah it
probably came off very very cocky but
I'm kind of cocky as a performer on
stage and I just need to recognize
that's what I am but I need to also
address it immediately
and do my set based off of that right
because I think it's just important that
that Cockiness or whatever that stage
presence is that's your comfort zone
that's kind of just who you are and
sometimes you're not going to recognize
it someone else has to be like hey you
come off in this way or Bookers or your
comedian friends I think that's an
important just feedback mechanism you
know people do that like in executive
worlds right like people do that like
you every CEO knows how they come off
when they're speaking every presenter
knows how they come off when they talk
like you should know how you come off or
how you look from other people it's just
important like
Insight so like because if you're it's
almost like if you're like too good
looking and you come off like as a guy
and you come off and start saying a
whole bunch of stuff about being ugly
the audience simply just isn't going to
believe you
yeah do you mean same thing for women
right the audience just like if a really
pretty person comes on stage and starts
going off about how ugly they are you're
like ah we just don't believe it but if
you address it immediately like I know
yeah I mean so it's just one of those
things that I think it's important that
you understand what you look like
overall
yeah I had to change it my
because I was too beautiful
that actually uh that reminds me of the
the feedback I got from a headliner was
like yeah remembering how you come off
to the audience because I was trying to
be like political and like tell the
audience how the world is and he's like
dude he's like you're like you have a
baby face you look like their kid it's a
Saturday night at 10 o'clock they don't
want to hear how the world works from
someone that looks like their kid so
it's like just remembering how you come
off uh it it really I really unlocked a
lot for me understanding how the
audience it almost becomes a filter of
what you're going through I've got both
you guys really well and I know both of
you think about every element of how you
look on stage what you're wearing
everything so many Comics don't and I
tell Comics I go if you're stuck in a
rut and your show's just kind of gliding
along and you don't know what to do with
it change your shirt
change your shoes wear a suit it's a
great idea don't wear
just sometimes just changing something
changes the way you personally inside
Phil and it could change your entire
show
talk about wearing a bowling shirt on
stage I did that because I started out
as a prop comic and I had a bone bag
full of [__] and I was wearing bowling
shoes and somebody said to me hey you
should wear a bowling shirt and I was
like okay when I put it on I I felt like
my show went from here to here just
because I felt silly and I knew I looked
the way I did which gave me the right to
get away with some silly stuff so I it
made me feel more comfortable on stage
okay so just yeah change something just
think about it if a comic goes up sloppy
looking like a slob I don't care if
that's if it looks like you thought
about it and that's your character but
if you look like you just rolled off the
couch and walked on stage
and that has nothing to do with it and
I'm like man you're wasting a whole
another level of your comedy by looking
a certain way
yeah it makes a big difference yeah yeah
so where can people uh and we'll link
this in uh the show notes as well oh and
Tavis all the way up in Canada was
saying he loves World Series and wishes
he could be on more stuff up in Canada
oh that's great
the world series of comedy.com just go
there I would tell any comic before they
register take a take a little bit of
time there's a lot of information on the
website click on the links go around
read all the [__] make sure it's what
you want to do make sure you understand
what you're spending the money on and
then when they register and right now
anybody who's listened to this or
whatever signs up make sure they put
down hot breath where they heard it and
we'll uh right now if you register you
get to pick when you register your
register for the main event and you can
pick one satellite but we still have uh
six
seven
maybe eight I'm not sure I think we have
eight satellites left I think you know
uh
if they say they didn't hurt here on hot
breath they register uh I'll add all the
other side lights for free
so they can have all all the satellites
added to their registration and if
you're somebody listen to this who has
already registered and they're like oh I
want that deal just email me you have my
email if you registered and I'll uh
update your registration for you and
give you the opportunity to hopefully
maybe get into more satellites if you
get that opportunity and get that chance
with your video uh World Series economy
the world series of comedy.com check it
out
registrations there
I uh I can't thank you guys enough for
having me on we need more comics in
Atlanta punchline coming up there's a
ton of comics in Atlanta sign up come oh
yeah yeah that's in April right
yeah I think so yes
the headshot the email for the the
Atlanta one Yoshi was front and center
on there I was like oh
yeah uh McCurdy's we go to McCurdy's
April 12th then uh April 19th through
the 22nd it's the punch line in Atlanta
such a great room they're so supportive
uh great if you live anywhere anywhere
around and you want that's a good one to
come to
yeah John Lewis says unemitted for that
one crossing my fingers nice
cool yeah so when you register let them
know there's a there's a place we can
say where you heard about the
registration and let them let them know
you heard it from a hot breath and
um get involved in more satellites for
free yeah they don't they don't just do
this for anyone but we we go we go way
back so this is uh it's always good we
can collaborate on stuff
we'll do it for anyone
we do it for anyone
[Laughter]
thanks for having me
thank you guys for watching live we love
you all so much
space where did you hear it from
everywhere you just heard it everywhere
that's what you put no hot breath just
put everywhere it's everywhere
we love you Joe appreciate it brother
yeah thanks for your time Joe and thanks
for having for hanging out on the live
stream or listening to the podcast
afterwards we do this every Tuesday at 5
00 p.m eastern time yeah yeah I would
also say if you're ever in the city
where uh a World Series is going on I
would also suggest just going to the
show and also just hanging out with the
comics the networking at the World
Series is so worth it
um I've gotten plenty of paid work from
hanging out and working
yep somebody hang out and meet us and
say hi
yeah thanks man yeah yep for sure yeah
well awesome well thanks everyone we'll
see y'all next Tuesday y'all have a good
day
hey
dab we dab at the end Joe you dab yeah
dab on them it looked terrible but hey
we'll take it
he doesn't want to show the top of his
head so he doesn't want to Bow too far
either
[Music]